So we have our object diagram started.
And right now these objects
are just kind of floating around.
We haven't really talked about
how they might be interconnected.
So let's add some connections or if
we're going to use the more formal term,
we'll say, let's add some relationships.
Relationships that we're going to add
are going to ones that we've borrowed
from UML and
those are the contains relationship and
the kind of relationship and
these are also known by other names.
For instance contains might
be known as part of and
a kind of might also
be known as a type of.
And there's other variations too.
So what do these mean?
Let's start with
the contains relationship.
Like it sounds, a contains relationship
is representative of when an object
contains another object.
If we think about the world object,
it contains a robot,
it contains an alien, has a background.
Also has a dialogue bubble and the.
But we're going to leave those out for
now.
So in our diagram, let's create some
relationships between the world and
the robot, the alien and the background.
So I'm going to go ahead and
move some things around just
to make some extra space.
And to represent
the contains relationship,
we'll draw arrows from the world object
to the objects that it contains and
label them as contains relationships.
Pay close attention to
the direction of the arrows.
For these relationships, it's
pointing from the world to the robot,
to the alien, and to the background.
And the reason that it points in
this direction is it allows us to
read the relationship by
just following the arrow.
Now we could also said
that the app contains
each of the objects in this diagram,
but if I'm going to add an arrow for
every single object in our diagram,
it could get a little hard to follow.
So to keep our diagram simple we just
want to add the contains relationships
from the app to the most
high level objects.
By high level I mean objects that are
bigger in the sense that they have more
complexity about them.
So for instance the World object is at
a higher level than the Alien object in
the sense that it probably has more
functionality contained within it.
Another way to think about it is that
the World probably plays a bigger role
as part of the app than the Alien does.
In general you want to keep this going
from the most high level object like
In this case the alien aventure
to the lower level objects.
So for instance an alien adventure
consists or contains a world,
world contains a robot,
robot can contain a badge and
we can add a relationship for
that later.
Now the distinctions that we're making
here in these relationships that
we're adding again they're
completely up to you.
Where I'm using a contains relationship
between the world and the alien, you
might use something else, or you might
not even have a relationship at all.
Or we're on labeling this
is a contains relationship.
I might not even have that.
I might even remove an alien adventure.
Because the world is kind of
the most high level object and
by the title here we know that we're
talking about the alien adventure app.
But again it's just personal preference,
you can do whatever you want to.
So moving on, let's talk about the other
relationship, the kind of relationship.
This is one of my favorites.
It's used to describe objects
that have similarities and
it also involves a little
bit of abstract thinking.
For instance let's think
about the alien and
the robot, they're actually pretty
similar, the robot and the alien.
And can animate, we saw that the robot
could move across the screen and
the alien is animating right now.
And they're both able
to speak to each other,
so in a sense they're a little
bit like actors in a play.
Now this is the abstract part, the
aliens and the robot are like actors in
a play, then why not add an object to or
diagram that represents an actor.
I mean that sounds pretty good to me,
an actor is an object they can be
animated and participates in discussions
and just like we said both the alien and
the robot are kinds of actors.
And that's how we'll add
this kind of relationship.
We'll start by adding
an actor to the diagram.
And then we'll add relationships from
the alien to the actor because an alien
is a kind of actor.
And from the robot, the actor because
the robot is a kind of actor.
And I hope you've noticed that for
this kind of relationships,
the direction of the arrows again,
we're going from the alien to the actor.
So it reads very naturally
an alien is a kind of actor.